where does Braille come from the story
begins in 1812 in France and a young boy
called Louie Braille he lost his sight
in one eye when he was three
this was the culprit a sharp tool called
an awl which he was playing around with
in his father's workshop his I got
infected and the infection spread to the
other eye by five Louis Braille was
completely blind
[Music]
but he was determined and he went on to
win a scholarship at Frances Royal
Institute for blind youth
at the time the system for reading was
pretty basic just raised letters on a
page so he started working on a new code
that will be quicker and more efficient
by the time he was fifteen brailles new
system was basically complete and the
first edition was published in 1829
Braille system was based on a military
code called night writing invented by
captain Charles Barbee a it was a system
of embossed dots and dashes that
soldiers could read safely with their
fingers on the battlefield at night
Braille simplified the system reducing
the cells from 12 to 6 raised dots so
they were the ideal size for a fingertip
to feel with one touch Braille created
his raised dots using an all the same
sharp tool that it caused his blindness
and a flat grille to keep the lines
straight and readable its read from left
to right like other European scripts
Braille is not a language it's a system
of writing which means it can be adapted
to different languages
Braille codes have been developed for
maths and scientific formulae Braille
loved music and invented a system of
Braille for writing music too
but the medical establishment was
conservative and brailles innovation was
slow to be adopted
he died of tuberculosis aged 43 two
years before his system was finally
taught at the Institute where he'd been
a student 100 years later he was
reburied at the pantheon in Paris in
honor of his work though his local
village insisted on keeping his hands
over time the system did spread
throughout the french-speaking world by
1882 it was in use across Europe and
have reached North America by 1916 a
universal Braille code for English was
formalized in 1932 Braille has been
revolutionary for many blind people
around the world but with the rise of
new technologies including computers
that talk literacy rates are on the
decline in 1999 a second eponym was
given to this extraordinary man a rare
type of asteroid was named 9 9 6 9
Braille by NASA a timeless tribute to a
great human being
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon